Speaker 1: Trumpist threats to the FBI, including
individual agents involved in the search warrant
served at Donald Trump's Mar a Lago and more
generally to the Justice Department are exploding.
We know that Trumpists are willing to do violence
in great numbers.
We saw it on January 6th and for being about
backing the blue and the thin blue line and
support the police and defend the police and
all of this different stuff.
They abandoned that immediately.
When it is not convenient, we saw it on January
6th, on January six.
All of a sudden the police officers at the
Capitol were trying to stop Trumpists from
getting inside.
They were engaging Trumpists and trying to
physically prevent them from staying inside.
And all of a sudden, police weren't the good
guys.
They were the bad guys.
They don't actually care about police the
same that they don't actually care about the
military.
Oh, always defend the military, etc..
And yet we saw with the Iraq war of George
W Bush very willing to just send our members
of the military into harm's way for no actual
good, empirically backed reason.
So we're seeing the exact same thing.
FBI and DHS warn of increased threats to law
enforcement and government officials after
the Mar a Lago search.
The threats which are occurring primarily
online and across multiple platforms, including
social media, web forums, video sharing and
image boards were identified by the FBI and
Department of Homeland Security in the days
following the FBI's authorized seizure of
11 sets of classified documents from the former
president's home, including four sets classified
top secret, according to the search warrant,
according to the bulletin.
The FBI and DHS have observed an increase
in violent threats posted on social media
against federal officials and facilities,
including a threat to place a so-called dirty
bomb in front of the FBI headquarters and
issuing general calls for civil war and armed
rebellion.
That includes threats that are specific in
identifying proposed targets, tactics or weaponry.
Hmm.
We also have this incident where three days
after the search, rickey shaffer jr.
Wearing a technical vest and armed with an
air style rifle, a nail gun attempted to forcibly
enter the fbi cincinnati office and described
the standoff.
It described the standoff with FBI and law
enforcement officers that ultimately resulted
in schaeffer's death.
This is obviously expected.
I said this on our first stream in when we
were streamed the day that it was learned
that this search warrant was acted on.
I said they are going to go after the FBI
and the DOJ.
These people are violent.
These people claim to back the blue, but that's
only when it's convenient.
That's when it's George Floyd.
That's when it's Antifa or Black Lives Matter.
But when it's their own, they no longer back
the blue.
And some of you said, David, that's hyperbole.
That's not going to happen.
Well, it is happening.
We've already had an armed guy show up at
the CNN feel of CNN FBI.
They may well show up at CNN as well at the
FBI field office in Cincinnati.
We are seeing the doxing of the individual
FBI agents who participated in serving the
search warrant.
And they are it's cause and effect.
That's all it is.
It's a direct result of the attacks on the
verbal attacks on the FBI, law enforcement
and the DOJ.
Trump did it.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE did it.
It's dozens and dozens of Republicans saying
defund the FBI.
This is a Gestapo.
The they are actually the criminals.
And this is the exact result.
And it's actually so bad.
I mean, we know the script.
We saw what happened on January six.
It's so bad that even a Fox host is saying
Trump should probably make it clear you shouldn't
go after the FBI agents.